in a first of its kind gathering more
than a hundred leaders from some of the
most powerful american companies
met virtually on saturday to talk about
efforts by republicans nationwide
to overhaul voting laws all this comes
after a bill passed in georgia
led to allegations of racism and threats
of retaliation against companies that
oppose it
at o'keefe is in washington for us ed
good morning to you what are these
companies hoping to do here
good morning tony happy monday the
high-powered zoo meeting signals a
larger move among u.s companies to
oppose voter suppression
and signals they won't fear reprisals by
politicians or others when speaking out
it's something we haven't seen of this
magnitude to date
attendees included top bosses from
walmart united airlines linkedin and amc
theaters
with some ceos even chiming in from
augusta georgia the site of the masters
golf tournament
the head of our parent company viacom
cbs also attended a company spokesman
declined to comment the nonpartisan
brennan center which tracks voting
proposals across the country found
lawmakers in 24 states
are moving at least 55 bills through
state legislatures
that would restrict voting access keep
in mind many of these bills are based on
the lie that the presidential election
was stolen
the executives discussed potential ways
to respond to these restrictive bills
including cutting off donations to
politicians who support them
and holding off on investing in those
states and the meeting came together
extraordinarily fast organizers tell us
they invited 120 ceos
with about 50 hours notice and sorry
90 of them opted to attend the next test
of the voting rights debate will be in
texas where legislators are currently
considering
two proposals that observers say might
ultimately gail
go farther than the new georgia law got
it ed thank you very much